i got a couple new dayton hypernova
videos
first this is him playing his this is
his guitar demo for the band
yeah i was excited
[Music]
you know what dayton reminds it to me
dave reminds me of like
[Music]
it's really good what all of us were in
like 8th and 9th grade yeah
like remember in eighth and ninth grade
other than a couple of like
overachievers mostly friends like you
knew most of us were just bombs
in eighth and ninth grade and like
remember when you're like eighth grade
you had like the friend that had like
six hobbies and he was bad at all of
them
like i want to be an artist but i also
want to play guitar and i want to do
like fashion design and they're like
just terrible
this is what he is he's a middle school
bum
[Music]
he thinks this is good
well he's got i think he probably tuned
in a little bit
a little bit
i think it's pretty good royce
reminds me of primus
i'm gonna skip ahead a little bit
oh good i skipped that five minutes and
it's the same thing
well it's maybe it's more like a mixture
of primus and like
fish they're calling them clapton
it's uh
yeah he's doing like fish songs like you
know the jam band stuff 12 minute long
[Music]
is he using an amp at all or i
[Music]
also you know what i just this is popped
in my head i have a question does
anybody out there know have they made an
amp app for phone yet i think they have
yeah
because it was just like as he's doing
that i'm like i'm wondering if they made
something you just plug into a phone and
actually a little lamb yeah
that would be dope but that's what it
sounds like he's using
[Music]
to be fair we [ __ ] on dating a lot i'm
gonna give him one compliment
he does look like a guitarist that's
true
[Music]
this is good dude
why doesn't he sing
[Music]
okay i can only do so much anyway that
was just a little warmer i don't
understand why isn't he saying like he
doesn't
you can't write some lyrics about like
christina ricci or some [ __ ]
this little warm up this is this is him
this is him talking to himself just so
you get background in the attic after
his mom made him mad
worst audio in the world
got these videos don't worry he starts
talking here in a second
which might be worse than him eating sun
chips
but my mom just went crazy harassing me
because i used the the restroom
in the house uh a second time over the
span of like
five minutes or so uh it wasn't the same
restroom i went downstairs
because i i after i used the restroom
upstairs after
peeing i went into the restroom i came
back
and the restroom door was shut upstairs
so i went downstairs
and i was so burning hot from how the
how hot and humid it is in the house
right now it's like the middle of
august right now and there's no air
conditioning in this house at all
uh the only air conditioning unit that
works in this house is in the living
room
and my older brother who's over twice my
size who's a skin
uh belligerent racism and anti-semitism
and
uh uh transphobia and homophobia and
everything like
i've never heard of this brother it's
the first time you've imagined them yeah
it's pretty deep
he hates uh he beats me right in front
of these people repeatedly
and he spends all his time in that
living room with that air conditioner
no one else has access to an air
conditioner in this house
um i have an ac unit in my bedroom
but it's broken it's been broken several
years they've never replaced it
and they underpay me they do not pay me
minimum wage
you could get it fixed you you don't pay
him in the middle he's about to explain
why he can't
but he lives in the house if they can't
you'll see but they pay everybody
cleaning their house and they're
harassing me and my mom just went crazy
at me
because i went to the downstairs
bathroom to wash my hands and
water down my hair slightly because i
was burning
hot and we live in a house that's
burning hot while meanwhile it's not
even technically
very warm right now and at the month of
august it's kind of slightly chilly so
i'm burning up and cold like constantly
shifting
between the climate outside and the
weight let's go to dayton hypernova with
the weather
being humid inside because this house
was built in the 1920s
and the year right now is 2020 so it's
been like almost 100 years
since this house is built and it's not
well insulated
anyway all of that ranting i just got
crazy harassed by her and it went
way out of control she's crazy harassing
me she has not paid me
at very much at all this year uh i am
employed by her and my father my her
husband
so they are my employers and they are
the most abusive
employers you can imagine verbally
abusive
physically abusive and i get beat in
front of them
by a dude over twice my size it's their
first son
who's a former uh ex he's an ex-boxer
he's a former
uh bodybuilder guy who's overweight now
and he's crazy and i'm skinny and i
barely maybe you should stop saying
things like that to him maybe it hurt
his feelings
that's why he's beating you up pounds
and it's ridiculous and i get beat right
in front of these people
and they don't care he said well you're
not dead and like what the
hell is wrong with you christian people
who have no actual values that you
preach
there's a new one by the way you're
hearing a lot of the normal stuff but
there's a new there is a new one that's
coming up you'll see oh we got a new
he's introduced he's peppering in some
new ones yeah
and it's terrible and i'm up here in the
attic right now and i i'm risking being
too loud really right now very tall
but it's like they could probably
overhear me slightly so it's crazy
they don't care they're not listening
this crazy bigotry and violence
and my mom doesn't even pay me when she
hires me over the span of 11 years
uh since 2009 i've been employed by
these people
and i work for them and i clean and i do
their laundry
and she's being a bigot and she's
harassing me and not paying me
where are you going to move out like i
need to get paid to move out
like i need to be able to afford it just
like you had to afford this house
and she's like an [ __ ] and she makes
a lot of money as an accountant
and she is a completely sinful
christian with no personal sense of
accountability despite the fact that
she's an accountant
she has no sense of accountability for
her own actions and she is
terrible and uh harassing me and she's
anti-semitic
she's blonde hair blue eyed hates jewish
people
new lore mama mama hypernova
mama hypernova new lore is she our
[ __ ] she our base mama
no lore actions and she is
terrible and uh harassing me and she's
anti-semitic
she's blonde hair blue-eyed hates
jewish people hates curly hair people
and tries to comb out all the
curls and the hair of any of her kids
she's a crazy ass person she hates
curly-haired people eh
i like right that's what she i like that
what if hear me out on this
i'm gonna help you i'm gonna help all
you wig nats and all you
[ __ ] white nationalist spurgs right
now
what if we just outlawed curly hair
can we do that by the way the other two
the other
two people you're talking about
someone's asking the chat is dashed in
the psychic vampire
oh that one's a yeah yeah dayton's way
less of a [ __ ]
actual nightmare than those people and i
have psoriasis all over my body head to
toe
passed out to me from her sister her
sister
passed down this genetic anomaly called
erythrodermic psoriasis which is a form
of psoriasis
which believes it's so severe that it
bleeds all over the body moisturize this
is a mild case
compared to what i've experienced i
experience it all over my entire body
it's not easy to get out of this
yeah that's weird you know some babies
are born like i don't know hooked on
crack
with aids so i mean you know everybody's
got their
thing also i love this thing i've been
working for them for 11 years you know
they've been
being nice for 11 years
giving you money to do honestly [ __ ] you
should probably just do anyway like oh i
do this and i i
straighten up and then i do some laundry
for people yeah well i mean you know
you're living there and you're eating
they're [ __ ]
they're buying your health burritos and
[ __ ] so maybe you do
maybe you do take the trash out like you
know what i mean like there's just stuff
you do
but it's like you're like i'm salaried
here sir i'll have you know and it's
like
i it's dude this lore with him from day
one has always been a nightmare
like did it just i don't even know we
never had anybody in the show more
entitled they think than [ __ ] dayton
hypernova
and this year i don't even really get
paid very much at all and these are
terrible
people who are going to hell which i
hope exists because bad people like them
belong there they don't belong in heaven
where i just have to be
after what i've been through he deserves
to be in heaven for what he's been
through
did you know that you know dayton
rope um
most people um
that declare i deserve to be in heaven
in the tone of a dennis reynolds
probably don't deserve to be in heaven
in my opinion
[Music]
oh is that sure the phone itself isn't
one of the sun chips
i might be i i don't know
this is what being a potato chip feels
like it is
you're getting bought you're getting
bought at a 7-eleven right now but
somebody's fighting with a significant
other on their cell phone
and you're hearing it's the crunching
and the moving and i don't know and i'll
get paid enough for the [ __ ]
who does my taxes every year she is my
own
accountant and she refuses to pay me
minimum wage
and she refuses to even really pay me
this year because she's selfish not for
any real reason i've been working every
week
it's crazy and i'm done with this [ __ ]
oh my god
brian are you opening the bag do we
finally are we finally free
are we free from our foiled prison
something that's caused it's correlated
i should say it's not caused by it but
it's correlated to stress
it spreads all over my body from anyone
harassing me which is what my mom does
this is what my father does which is
what my family members do which is what
my brother does while he's
beating me and thrusting his fist into
my body
and fighting for calling him son chip
chipperson
all these people over and over again and
i don't know how to get out of the
situation financially when they're not
paying me
what i deserve
it's like it's i feel like i feel like
i'm in an fbi field office and i'm like
so uh just the question where did you
where did you plant the bug you know
like i planted it in a bag of
pretzels and you're like why did you
who told you that was a good idea i just
figured he wouldn't see the microphone
in the bag of pretzels
all right well that's that was a
terrible idea agent i think you're fired
he's doing good though i think he's
doing great
you know i can i say this i'll give him
credit
i just watched two whole videos of
somebody and not a single mention of
coronavirus
his narcissism is so strong it's nice
though it's so strong
that not even coronavirus can can
penetrate it
that's almost i i almost envy the guy
right now